بينما يدعو الرئيس بايدن لمزيد من
المساعدات الأمريكية لأوكرانيا وكذلك لإسرائيل،
أريد أن ألقي نظرة على ما قدمته
الولايات المتحدة حتى
الآن.
هل يمكنك أن تخبرنا جيدًا أنه منذ
غزو روسيا لأوكرانيا في أوائل عام 2022، أرسلت الولايات المتحدة
دبابات وصواريخ ومدفعية ومروحيات وطائرات بدون
طيار وأنظمة دفاع صاروخية،
وتنقل القوات حمولات رادارية من
أسلحة ومعدات المشاة وما إلى ذلك
في إجمالي المساعدات التي تزيد قيمتها عن 75 مليار دولار.
ذهبت إلى أوكرانيا من الولايات المتحدة
والإنفاق العسكري هذا الجزء
هنا يمثل أكثر من نصف هذا
الإجمالي وهو أكثر بكثير مما ترسله الولايات المتحدة
إلى أي دولة أخرى وهو
يتضاءل تمامًا المساهمات الأمريكية
لإسرائيل التي كانت في عام 2021 في
النطاق النموذجي  من 3 إلى 4 مليار لورا، أعني
أن مجرد رؤية الأرقام
المذكورة، من المذهل حقًا التفكير
فيها وهذا فرق كبير، أعني أن
لدينا استطلاع رأي حديث لشبكة سي إن إن، أفكر
في ما يفكر فيه الأمريكيون بالفعل بشأن
ما وصفته للتو، فلنبدأ
بإسرائيل  ماذا قالت تلك الاستطلاعات،
نعم، إذا نظرت إلى أن
التعاطف الأمريكي مع إسرائيل يشهد ارتفاعًا حقيقيًا
في الوقت الحالي، لذا قد تتوقع
دعمًا قويًا لهذا
القدر المتواضع نسبيًا من الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية لإسرائيل، لكن الأرقام
ترسم صورة أكثر قتامة، حيث يقول 35٪ من الأمريكيين
المستوى الحالي للمساعدات
صحيح تقريبًا: 15% يقولون إنه أكثر من اللازم، و14% يقولون إنه
قليل جدًا، و36% من أكبر
مجموعة هنا يقولون إنهم غير متأكدين،
وملاحظة جانبية مثيرة للاهتمام في هذه
الأرقام تظهر أن الجمهوريين وأولئك
الذين يشاهدون الأخبار  نحن عن كثب أكثر
تفضيلًا لهذا المستوى الحالي من مساعدات
لورا، فماذا عن تمويل أوكرانيا، هل
هناك استطلاع للرأي حول ذلك نعم نعم
لدينا واحد من الخلف في أغسطس وفي هذه
الحالة يظهر انخفاضًا كبيرًا منذ
الأيام الأولى للحرب عندما كان هناك عدد كبير من الناس  فضل
غالبية الأمريكيين المساعدة
لأوكرانيا سواء كان ذلك بسبب
طول الصراع أو المبلغ الخام
الذي تم إرساله بهذه الطريقة. 55% من
الأمريكيين هذا العدد هنا
يقولون حاليًا إنه
لا ينبغي أن يكون هناك تمويل إضافي لأوكرانيا و
45%  يقول إن الأموال يجب أن تستمر في التدفق،
وهنا يقول الجمهوريون إن هذا
إنفاق كافٍ لأوكرانيا، وهم
يعارضون بشدة المزيد من الإنفاق،
ويفضل الديمقراطيون بشدة المزيد من الأموال
للقتال ضد الروس، لذا فإن كل
هذه الأرقام تجمع كل هذا معًا
وتجمع الاضطرابات في الكابيتول هيل
هذا ما سيواجهه الرئيس بايدن
عندما ألقى هذا الخطاب الليلة وما
سيواجهه في
الأيام القادمة، شكرًا لك توم فورمان على تفصيل
كل ذلك، لقد كان من المفيد حقًا رؤية
الأرقام هناك، وأنا أقدر
ذلك